you wanna drink are you this for me
really yeah they're all for you morning
blitz dude yeah yeah morning blitz
killed you won't it sounds I got very it
let's plan yeah yeah yeah that should be
a drink Hitler's plan yeah oh the double
iPad huh what happens that what happened
oh you are so you're covered both eyes
yeah but the Mencia dude Mencia was on
stage at the addison improv there's a
brick wall right and I was in the late
90s I was his opener and some dude in
the late what 1990s in the 1990s what
90s would have been 18 yep nineteen
1990s yeah yeah yeah I should say the
nineteen part I don't know dude I just
asked you was the nineteen nineties what
do you say it's my house
okay alright let me start then my hand
smell like poop no let me start oh yes
awesome
oh this like that game show driver and
yeah this is like that African games are
doing poop on me African game show
they did that yes the game shows in
Africa bro the second round you get you
can get murdered what got lose his arm
no my story you no no no I want to hear
more about it so 1990 late 1990s 1990s
and some dude threw a [ __ ] bottle on
stage right and this yeah yeah like and
he dodged it right he did like a George
Bush like he you know me a shoe thing
yeah and then um
there was a riot literally like just saw
table attacking each table the ambulance
comes
Oh God right it cops come right now
you're an hour and lights are on
audience are still hanging out though
people are taking like down you know
witness reports I don't know how they do
it you know nobody's to take people's
word for it oh yeah what happened
somebody just tell you what happened you
believe them
yeah yeah before you could even like
prove DNA yeah no CCTV no nothing and
they just plant and you know a lot of
times back in the day these to blame
just black people black I did it and
they'll arrest the first one records by
I'm gonna kill but then also there was a
lot of times real black I did it right
date but yeah they would pick up any
black guy and that kind of [ __ ] wasn't
cool of course it's not it's
unfathomable it's the next word
kalila looks like one of the prettiest
but also the worst superhero to dead
eyes
I have no any way after the please Kate
laughs and the ambulance left scary
Mencia said he's doing the show so
everyone sat back down and he did an
hour and a half but after like an hour
of people I would have just said show's
over
right yeah yeah but he didn't do it and
he did it Wow you know so that's just
one positive story out of a million
negative stories about him you know he's
always nice whenever I don't know he's
always nice in a rush see him yeah he
just got it yeah I mean he just had I
guess he was taking material and that's
what people said he was doing did you
know that he was doing that was it that
evident or were you into it you know I
think I honestly I don't know that much
about it at all I'm gonna tell you what
it is and that was a lot of it but I
think equally as bad was him bumping
people back in the 90s so you know back
you know when you you know did you want
up this weekend right at the store or
last week sometime
yeah what time do you get spots about
9:45 10:00 right yeah I'm more like
11:00 11:00 so if he gives you an 11:00
hot spot right when you show up at the
club you think you're gonna get up
between 11:00 11:15 right yeah but back
in the late 90s if you're at 11 o'clock
spot it meant people didn't even show up
Wow because they knew that they wouldn't
be able to get up damn because they knew
that Mencia or Eddie Griffin or some of
these guys and they would do 3 or 4
hours on stage what yeah they let him go
yeah they let him go and they did that
every night and there was like Mitzi
just let him go yeah like four or five
of them it's very bizarre that she would
let him do that I remember one time
Rogan and I Eddie Griffin went up for
hours and Rob and I were in the lock
not the lobby but out on the patio and
we're just sitting there and we're goes
I'm gonna leave I mean I met you can't
you think Joe Rogan
what he is now you know men but they
used to do to him Wow and um imagine all
the people that Mencia bumped he bumped
Whitney Cummings and everyone that's big
now right everyone that's a regular now
at the store was the people that he
bumped for years a lot of the resentment
and hatred the fuel have
has now if you learn them but it also
made them hate the man OSE over the
years so then imagine when the guy was
down from from stealing jokes and then
people came out of the woodwork and said
yeah I mean he's an ass right well yeah
at that point yeah you got everybody
wouldn't already be an [ __ ] that's
why I think we're very lucky to be in
this new golden age of the Comedy Store